biscarrosse le décollage d'un dragon et
400 mètres plus bas une croix au centre
de deux cercles concentriques
c'est là que les concurrents du
championnat france de parachutisme
devait poser les pieds on se dirige en
tirant sur les suspentes et c'est déjà
bien d'arriver dans le cercle
l'épreuve de précision à partir de 15
sans m'être comporté ainsi quatre sauts
il faut rappeler que seuls conte plein
droit ou les pieds ont touché le sol
[Musique]
l'adjudant arassus qui devait confirmer
son titre de champion de france a réussi
dans cette épreuve
un très joli saut à 60 centimètres du
sang
[Musique]
au stade de l'année car astugue à plus
de 10000 gymnastes appartenant à 17
nations s'affrontent dans une vaste
compétition qui porte sur les exercices
les plus classiques de ce sport aux
anneaux d'abord pour un équilibre en
force
puis aux barres parallèles où les
concurrents rivalisent de légèreté comme
de puissance
et voici maintenant pour terminer un
exercice d'ensemble au tremplin dans
lequel les gymnastes semble défier les
lois de la pesanteur
et
à porto novo sa capitale actuelle comme
à cotonou sa capitale futur la jeune
république du dahomey à célébrer le
premier anniversaire de son indépendance
devant l'assemblée nationale réunie en
séance solennelle le président de la
république monsieur hubert maga a évoqué
les efforts et les résultats d'une année
d'indépendance et insisté sur les
avantages de la collaboration française
magnifique exemple at il dit est gage
d'une amitié solide qui ne se démentira
pas le lendemain à cotonou le président
maga passait en revue les unités de la
jeune armée d'annonay
[Musique]
ces unités qui comporte toutes les armes
devaient ensuite défiler devant un
public enthousiaste
ce défilé devait être complété à porto
novo par un défilé populaire qui mettait
en relief les forces vives du pays
sans oublier bien entendu ce pittoresque
traditionnelle d'un vieux peuple porté à
l'état de jeune nation
larry à vue ou quai d'orsay les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
quatre messieurs dean rusk l'ordre youm
fun brentano et couve de murville réunis
pour fixer la position occidentale sur
le problème de berlin toujours au
premier plan des préoccupations
les quatre ministres devaient notamment
envisager certaines mesures militaires
et économiques
berlin n'a pas fini de faire parler de
lui
et
oh
[Musique]
ça rase sur la côte du pays basque
espagnol sonore de compter deux
visiteurs de marque le roi baudouin et
la reine fabiola les souverains sont
venus passer la des vacances familiales
ils sont en effet les autres du beau
frère et de la soeur de la reine des
belges
pas de vacances actuellement pour bébé
qui est arrivé à rome pour aller
poursuivre à spolète le tournage du film
de louis malle
il va sans dire que l'apparition de la
vedette française numéro un n'est pas
passé inaperçu on assure même que les
cameramen et photographes en un an non
gardé quelques courbatures et quelques
bleus
quant à brigitte inquiète de tant de
chaleur elle n'a songé qu'elle se
réfugier dans sa voiture pauvre bébé
à mayenne c'est un souvenir
particulièrement émouvant que sont venus
évoquer avec toute la ville deux
américaines madame n'a craqué mais sa
fille près du pont qui porte aujourd'hui
leur nom c'est une belle histoire
le 5 août 1944 ndiaye avait réussi tout
seul à empêcher les allemands de faire
sauter le dernier pot il permet ainsi à
l'armée patton de continuer son avance
mais il y avait laissé la vie ce jazz sa
pleine à craquer son visage les
habitants de mayenne ont pu l'oublier
ils n'oublieront ni son nom ni son
sacrifice
[Musique]
nous ne sommes plus au temps où
l'amateur de nage sous marine était un
être singulier 15 ans ont changé tout
cela et qui paie aujourd'hui de masques
et de bouteilles d'air les nageurs sous
marin est maintenant un autre banal de
la plage et s'il en est pour qui le fond
de la mer est un terrain de chasse ou de
recherche
si les pêcheurs d'un fort entre
maintenant dans la même légende que les
pêcheurs de perles tous les plongeurs
sous-marins n'appartiennent pas à cette
élite des bas fonds
il y a aussi la foule banale des deux
mètres de fond ce que nous appellerons
les sous l'eau la plage on la connaît
comme dit l'autre ce n'est plus une
plage c'est une foule une foule au ras
du sol de cet observatoire commode et
confortable on voit se diriger vers la
mer des paires de jambes de toutes les
élégances de tous les âges de toutes les
prudents et de toutes les hardiesses
[Musique]
pour y chercher sans doute un peu de
solitude
[Musique]
enfin seule la solitude la tranquillité
la paix pas si vite
le sous l'eau et la invisible qui vous
dévisagent juge votre forme sportive
s'offrent avec une indiscrétion qu'on
pourrait parfois dire blâmable le
spectacle que vous donnez et mon dieu
même un homme dans l'eau peut être
ridicule attention à cet observateur
indiscrets on peut voir sous l'eau de
ces choses que vous espériez bien ne pas
avoir découvert et puis dans cette
tricou vous vous sentiez au bout du
monde maintenant plus de sécurité
l'ennemi peut sournoisement s'approcher
et soudain apparaît quel problème car
avec cette prolifération des sous l'eau
n'allons nous pas voir le fond de la mer
devenir aussi peuplé que la plage
va-t-il falloir qu'ils transportaient
les règlements de la circulation et
créer un corps d'agents pourri manier le
bâton blanc
[Musique]
finira tôt par jouer au naturel sur une
terrasse sous marine la fameuse partie
de cartes d'un pagnol devenue cette fois
parfaitement pleinement totalement
méditerranéen
[Musique]